bonne nouvelle pour la haute mer cette
zone qui commence à maximum 370 km des
côtes représentent plus de 60% des
océans mais jusqu'à présent elle n’était
que très peu régulée juridiquement et
longtemps ignoré du combat
environnemental malgré la pollution et
la surpêche or ces océans fournissent la
moitié de l'oxygène que l'on respire
regorge d'une biodiversité microscopique
foisonnante et limite le réchauffement
climatique en absorbant du gaz
carbonique
le navire a atteint le rivage s'est
réjouit la présidence de la conférence
plus de 190 États membres de l'ONU sont
finalement parvenus à un accord cette
entente donne une possibilité de
protéger la bille université dans deux
tiers des océans
comment d'abord en créant des airs
marines dans les eaux internationales
pour protéger 30% des océans d'ici 2030
ensuite les gouvernements devront
procéder à des études d'impact des
activités en haute mer peut régulariser
pour le moment enfin l'accord inclus en
meilleure partage des ressources marines
entre pays pauvres et pays riches chaque
État membre droit
articuler ses grands principes-là à
savoir est-ce qu'ils vont être
contraignants ou non contraignants
bordés de trois océans d'îles et
d'archipel le Canada a en tout cas tout
à gagner d'un tel accord selon l'experte
je pense que ça va renforcer la
protection de l'environnement
qui est prêt du Canada notamment dans le
Nord avec le retrait des glaces il va y
avoir de plus en plus de fréquentations
de souhaits d'exploiter les ressources
qui sont dans ces milieux là il faudra
toutefois encore un peu de patience le
texte doit être relu par les services
juridiques et traduits avant d'être
ratifiés par les États un processus qui
peut durer 2 à 3 ans ici Camille
fairizen Radio-Canada Montréal